russian missiles have struck the central
ukrainian city of vinitsa the this is
mobile phone footage of the aftermath of
the attack local authorities say that at
least three missiles hit an office block
and damaged nearby residential buildings
at least 12 people are reported dead and
many more
are wounded
but for the latest let's cross over to
dws and economy in kievnik a severe
attack in the heart of ukraine very far
away from the front lines that we know
of what war can you tell us
well exactly the nearest frontline
fighting to venice is about 400
kilometers away this city that hadn't
seen much in the way of attacks from the
air since the early part of the war when
military airfields on the edge of city
were hit by the russians first real
attack on the downtown area um pretty
extraordinary images coming now through
social media from vinitsa presidency
lenski talking of russia as a terrorist
state uh near the ukrainian line and all
this that this is a
decided a kind of conscious tactic by
the russians to hit civilian targets in
the hope that this will spread panic and
terror behind the front lines will
encourage ordinary ukrainians to put
pressure on their own government to
basically give in to russia to come to
some kind of deal on moscow's terms
given that russia isn't making the
progress on the front lines through
traditional fighting that they had
expected
now what does this tell us then about
the direction that this war is currently
taking it's a sign of strength from the
russians or rather a sign of desperation
i think it's a bit of both i think this
is russia once again trying to show
ukraine but also the west that there is
no corner of this country that is safe
from russian missiles has to be said the
ukrainians say they were able to
intercept several missiles this morning
so this
three managed to hit vinitza but
allegedly another four were
hit were intercepted but i think the
bigger picture is indeed that russia is
struggling is really increasingly
frustrated especially with western
weapons deliveries coming now western
rocket artillery the highmar systems
we've seen a string of ukrainian hits on
russian logistics hubs on russian
ammunition depot
and we've seen now in recent days
basically the artillery
along the front lines the russian
artillery that had been so effective in
recent weeks we've seen russia with
hugely superior resources at its
disposal now really going quiet because
they're basically being starved of
ammunition by those ukrainian strikes so
a sense there that russia now is
increasingly having to rely on missiles
that it can release from its own
territory far away from where the
ukrainians can get at it and basically
in desperation now trying to basically
throw these kind of heavy weapons around
them in some hope that they managed to
break the ukrainian result but that's
not something that seems to be working
for now but definitely a reminder to
anyone here in ukraine that when they
hear that air raid signal aerated alarm
however far away they are from the front
lines it's probably worth trying to go
for cover because there is really
nowhere that is safe even if you're far
away from a front line or from a
military target
dws nick connolly for us in the
ukrainian capital key thank you nick